In this section, we will wrap up this course with a few final recommendations, providing
some tips and resources for you to use as you continue your training with MetaHumans
in Unreal Engine.
MetaHumans provide a digital human pipeline that can fit into any workflow.
Let's take a look at vertical specific applications they can easily be integrated into.
In architectural visualization, MetaHumans can be used to add life to an environment
and create a sense of scale.
In automotive product design, they can add a human touch to a digital product and can
even be used for digital car showroom presentations.
In film and television, they can be used as digital doubles of real world actors performing
in a digital world.
They can also be used to pre-visualize performances with real-time animation workflows.
For games, they can be used for high quality cinematics, playable characters, and easily
be integrated into UEFN.
That's it for this section.
Next, we will go over some tips and resources that may be helpful when working with MetaHumans.